ça comme à chaque mercredi nous avons
rendez vous avec notre rubrique cinéma
et avant de découvrir les trois compères
vavoua michel mompontet comment échapper
ce matin à l'événement franco gloire du
pastis et obélix contre césar c'est le
titre de la superproduction signée
claude zidi jamais un film français
n'avait atteint un tel budget a été
diffusée dans autant de salles le
producteur a lancé ce matin 7 140 copies
à travers toute la france
voici tout de suite les premières
réactions des spectateurs non
professionnels c'est-à-dire le grand
public grec réactions recueillies ce
matin donc par philippe deslandes
c'est quand même très gros budget et on
le voit sur l'écran ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas
donc c'est intéressant et je pense qu'il
faut il faudrait le voir effectivement
moi je recommanderais alors autour de
moi trouve que ça manque de rythme c'est
tout ce qui peut dire s'il ya des
moments où on s'ennuie
j'ai beaucoup aimé cdac s'assemblant la
bd surtout le paquet et spéciaux
entre en vain là où saab a rigolé ouais
c'est la première fois qu'on voit des
biens
oui c'est fantastique léger américain en
attaque 7 millions au carreau
l'appréciation du superbe sommes dues
aux superbes alors